uh in 1861 Abraham Lincoln uh the leader
of the original Republican Party
uh during the secession crisis a crisis
like no other in American history
decided uh forthrightly that he he and
his party would stand up to secession
uh they did not acquiesce in secession
Lincoln told his uh supporters uh he
said let there be no compromise on the
question of extending slavery if there
be all our labor is lost and air long
must be done gone
to a southerner he wrote on the
territorial question I am in flexible
now
um
if Lincoln had not stood up to secession
the United States would have been two
countries and a whole different history
would have flowed from it uh Speed Ahead
to 1933 when Franklin Roosevelt was in
was inaugurated uh he inherited a
massive economic depression and 25
unemployment his predecessor Herbert
Hoover had taken a kind of laissez-faire
approach to the Great Depression doing
very little
Roosevelt energized government they
passed overnight the Banking Act and
then a whole series of other enactments
that became known as the New Deal which
didn't necessarily save American
capitalism but it certainly made strides
in that direction Roosevelt could have
backed off and said you know this
problem is just too vast and complicated
we can't we can't deal with it go ahead
to uh 1965 when Lyndon Johnson
supported after his land slide election
the previous year the 1964 and 65 Civil
Rights Acts especially the Voting Rights
Act Lyndon Johnson an old segregationist
could have said
I understand this white supremacy I was
one of them uh we can't we can't stop
this I'm not going to get on board for
voting rights because it's going to
destroy my political party the Democrats
in South forever he was not wrong about
that
now think of 9 11 when the United States
decided to stand up to terrorist
organizations like Al Qaeda and went
into Afghanistan to find Al Qaeda what
if we had said you know this is just too
big this is just two
complex of account of a war that we do
not know how to fight
now
it is not
I repeat not illegal to be mendacious
it is not illegal to lie
about an election you lost
the big lie in other words is not
illegal
it is not illegal to be ignorant of
History
or ignorant of law in the Constitution
which the previous president has
demonstrated
he is
uh it's not illegal to ferment racism
with rhetoric at least and or behavior
it's not even illegal to Cozy up to
foreign dictators such as Orban
or Kim Jong-un or Vladimir Putin what
what president Trump did in Helsinki
by saying he uh he actually believed
Vladimir Putin more than his own
intelligence agencies was not illegal
uh it might have been politically unwise
but not illegal it's not illegal to
spread misinformation about covid from
the White House briefing room it's not
illegal to maintain over and over that
Barack Obama wasn't born in the United
States it's not illegal to be an extreme
narcissist uh it's not illegal to insult
reporters or to insult women by
suggestions of sexual abuse
uh it is not illegal to insult NATO
members I could go on there are many
kinds of behavior
that are not illegal they certainly are
impeachable offenses and this president
was impeached twice impeachment
is a political process not a legal
process but it is illegal
to engage in obstruction of Congress and
its proceedings under Title 18 section
1805 of the federal criminal code
it is illegal
uh under the section three of the 14th
Amendment to incite an Insurrection
against the United States government as
long as it can be proven
it is illegal to engage in conspiracy to
defraud the United States in Title 18
section 370 one of the criminal code
um it uh that that criminal code is is
in part about cheating the government
out of money or property but it's also
about using deceit the law says to
obstruct a government function
um
the to violate the Sedition uh
conspiracy act which is Title 18 section
2384 the criminal code it is illegal to
collaborate with leaders of a mob
interested in overthrowing the U.S
capital or a procedure of the U.S
Congress if that can be proven wire
fraud is very illegal if it can be shown
that a former president used enormous
lies to raise money from his supporters
it is illegal to participate in a
violation of the Espionage Act which the
recent search at Mar-A-Lago at least
suggested as one of their background
laws section 793 of the criminal code
makes it makes it unlawful to retain
defense related information that could
Aid a foreign enemy in section 1519
destroying and concealing documents to
obstruct government proceedings is
illegal and in section 2071
it is unlawful to remove government
records from their appropriate locations
and to willfully or unlawfully that law
says conceal them now last point
um
we have we do have dysfunctional
institutions but we shouldn't fear that
we have them
um it is not illegal to be blameworthy
of something
but it is illegal to break laws openly
willfully
uh we should
we should not fear the virulence of the
right-wing supporters of this former
president and thereby back off from
prosecutions however long and however
difficult they may be
it is fear
that drives the argument it seems to me
that we should not prosecute this former
president we should fear some have
argued the cross-examination that Trump
would be put under in a courtroom why
would we fear cross-examination and
lastly
why do we fear continuing this melodrome
drama
this uh Spotlight that a prosecution
would continue to shine on Donald J
Trump
when he has violated it appears numerous
laws if we fear Prosecuting a former
president merely because it continues
the kinds of drama which is his branding
that he so enjoys then why do we have
law at all if we truly believe in rule
of law we will not approach the
prosecution of Donald J Trump through
fear but through belief that maybe just
maybe some of our institutions
for example the justice system
can be put to the service of Truth
thank you David thank you very much I'm
Philippa Thomas I'm joining Connor in
hosting this debate and we're asking
members of the audience to hold your
opinions because of course we have to
hear the other side in this uh this
motion to prosecute Trump uh we want to
invite you to hear the case against at
our speaker against the motion is Rich
Lowry editor-in-chief of National Review
and American conservative news and
opinion magazine uh Rich writes a
regular column for Politico he appears
regularly on public affairs programs
such as Meet the Press is the author
also of three books including the case
for nationalism how it made us powerful
United and free Rich you also have five
minutes to begin your case before I come
back and the audience has their turn
thanks so much well thanks for
Intelligence Squared for hosting these
debates are more important than ever
honored to be here with David blight
there's something called open courses at
Yale allows you to listen to entire
lecture series I listen to the entirety
of one Davis classes on the Civil War so
I'm basically a former student of David
maybe not one of his favorite former
students but a kind of former student so
just to situate myself I'm a
Conservative Republican but I'm opposed
to Donald Trump so don't take my word
for for it this is I'm reading from a
truthsocial post by Donald Trump himself
a couple weeks ago refers to Rich Lowry
who was destroyed the what's wonderful
and influential National Review the
pride and joy of the legendary William F
Buckley so I'm not a trump guy but I am
opposed to this resolution I think there
are three tests one did Trump clearly
and unambiguously violate the law would
this be good for the country Prosecuting
him and would it serve the extremely
important political goal of making sure
he doesn't win a nomination again and is
not elected president of the United
States again if this resolution fails
any of those tests that should go down
as it happens it fails all three so the
fact of the matter is and David alluded
to this sum once you get out of the
political and moral realm where clearly
what Trump did was abysmal atrocious
literally Infamous and get into the
legal realm then you're in a Zone where
inherently technicalities and mincing
distinctions matter it's no longer just
a rhetoric these words really count key
thing corrupt intent almost all the
these supposed charges that uh he'd be
prosecuted on involve corrupt attempt
which means demonstrating that he didn't
sincerely believe that the election was
stolen and I hate to say it I think he
is truly fired with a passionate
intensity and sincerity on this stuff I
think if you put him on a lie detector
test he would pass it without question
making some of these outlandish claims
doesn't speak well with him but just
shows that there's no way you're going
to establish the requisite intent
incitement's a word that's been bandied
about incitement very specific in U.S
law it means a clear and knowing a call
to violence right it just doesn't mean
being Reckless it means a clear and
knowing call for uh imminent violence
you're not going to prove that
Insurrection again you can throw it
around it's good to write in op-eds but
it has a specific meaning and U.S
statutes Rebellion that can't be put
down just by uh law enforcement that's
not going to apply here obstructing
Congress so if it's a crime for members
of Congress to object to the electors
when the other Party's candidate wins
the presidential race then there are
many Democrats who are guilty of exactly
the same crime including leaders of the
January 6 committee yes it was insane
for Trump to think that Mike Pence could
unilaterally change the the count of the
electors on January 6 but we don't
prosecute people for insane legal
theories and then just to underline this
point that technicalities matter once
you're in you're in the legal realm once
you're in the courtroom we all know the
call that Trump had in Georgia with the
Secretary of State you got to find me 11
000 votes if you actually read the
transcript of that call which is what
will happen in a court of law Trump
makes it clear he thinks there's a pool
of 400 000 fraudulent votes so it's not
just saying go manufacture 11 000. he's
saying go find these votes that I know
are fraudulent he has two or three
lawyers on the call with him people
usually don't commission felonies with
in the company of their lawyers and the
lawyers say look we've done fine-grained
analysis we believe there are tens of
thousands fraudulent votes and the
takeaway at the end of the call is can
we have a meeting with you Secretary of
State's office and you can explain how
we we're wrong I'm sorry no one is going
to jail for that call no one is going to
jail for that call so the legalities
really matter and they're just they're
just not here now sec second test is it
good for the country no whatever we
might like if you saw the reaction to
the FBI search and you thought that was
over the top and hysterical just wait
just wait to to he's prosecuted you
think this country is divided now just
wait until you try to to uh prosecute
him there's a reason we honor Gerald
Ford for pardoning Richard Nixon because
he got the country out of a box now you
have people affirmly saying we need to
get in to this box and we'll invite
retaliation you prosecute Trump
Republicans win the presidency in 2024 I
guarantee you Joe Biden will be
prosecuted for something by the
republican-led justice department maybe
having to do with the sleazy dealings of
a son Hunter Biden and then finally the
name of the game here is make sure
Donald Trump is not president again the
FBI search was the best day political
he's had in a very long time if you
prosecute him it'll even be better for
him so in summary the chant Locker up
when Republicans were saying that about
Hillary Clinton was dumb and unworthy
the same is true of lock him up this
resolution must and should fail
rich thank you very much powerful stuff
from both of you and I think this is a
good point in which to reveal the
results of the poll to see who has the
greatest challenge here and we can say
that coming into this debate for the
idea that Don J Trump should be
prosecuted 81 percent
Rich The Challenge is
things are always darkest before they go
completely black
five percent say no but 14 are undecided
I find that uh particularly interesting
uh now we are going to bring in audience
questions uh and I'm just going to
remind you that uh Connor's told you
about how to do that to click on the ask
question tab tell us your name if you
want your name to be read out as part of
the question
um but before we start audience
questions uh first a short apology from
me uh yes we do know how to video
conference but Mia Culper my internet
fell off the air the minute we started
that hasn't happened to me before in
years of actually presenting television
from my living room during pandemic so
my apologies to the Intelligence Squared
audience that was me let's hope it
doesn't happen again but um Connor is
safely with you to share with you
through can I pick up
um just a thought for for David and and
for Rich here because there doesn't seem
to be a real debate between you about
the morality of the actions of Donald J
Trump but we heard from Rich there a
very strong case that Donald Trump
believes he won Donald Trump believes
there were pools of extra voters that
weren't counted he believes he was
swindled out of his second term David
who are we to say we can judge his
psyche that he's making it up
we're not judging his psyche and he's
not being put on trial if he's put on
trial for his beliefs uh it is the
federal code against
conspiring to defraud the United States
where the Georgia phone call which which
brought up uh would be prosecuted and in
that law it says using deceit
to thwart a government function can
anybody listen to that call to the
Secretary of State of Georgia and say
Trump was not making something up does
it matter whether he believed it his
actions in all of these cases his
actions are what should be prosecuted
not his beliefs we would be here forever
trying to prosecute Donald Trump for
immoral acts and in fact immorality
isn't necessarily illegal is it but
actions violating federal law yes they
are and and to what extent are we going
to continue to argue that this man is so
disassociated with truth
that he is incapable of knowing his own
actions
yeah I'm sorry just as a matter of Law
and I know this isn't satisfying but as
a matter of law any number of these
supposed charges do require corrupt
intent and David even just what you said
deceit that deceit means a willful
effort to mislead you know it's wrong
you know you're lying and you you do it
anyway and I'm just saying as a matter
of law look I don't think it's it's
worse that he believes this stuff as a
moral matter as a political matter it's
worse it makes it more important that he
should go away and be defeated
politically but legally it's not just
the act it is the intent and if and
again David I think is conceded the
point by the use of that word deceit as
a very specific meaning in the law and
again I think we both agree about this
we're not talking about morality we're
talking about the law and the law is
often unsatisfying if you are just
seeking a moral or political outcome
which I think I understand the impulse
which I think a lot of people are doing
here but it's misapplied in the legal
realm it will backfire you'll end up
losing the case you'll end up losing the
case and giving him a bigger Victory
which would be just perverse so don't go
down the route in the first place but
Rich can I just pick up on this point
because there is an argument that uh the
case will be lost he'll gain support
he'll emerge from this stronger but
isn't the the point of principle
that doesn't make it right to leave him
be if there are clearly indictable
offenses here if if there are clearly
indictable offenses which there aren't
so I have a multi-layered argument just
on on the legalities I don't think David
has made a case
um I don't think the case is is there
and if you're going to be you can't be
the least bit adventurous or novel in a
case that this that is this
consequential that that's just a very
bad thing if he shoots someone on Fifth
Avenue you know if the Midtown
prosecutor is investigating shootings in
Midtown Manhattan and arises that Donald
Trump shot someone on Fifth Avenue
there's no doubt right and we don't need
to know why I did it even he shot him
okay prosecutive but this is all
extremely uh murky and a lot of it
involved I'm sorry to say you know a lot
of it involves intent
but Rich you're saying that Donald
Trump's intent is only to be judged by
some small group of lawyers who were
sitting with him when he made that call
to the Secretary of State that he is
utterly incapable of knowing his own
intent I'd like to see some prosecutors
with him on the stand take him to task
about just what he knows and doesn't
know
no I I that's not what it is
psyche is not on trial his actions are
well again David intent matters so if
you say a psyche is not on trial you're
saying intent doesn't matter as a matter
of black and white long a number of
these statutes the intent does matter
and I'm not saying it's it's the
Judgment of a couple lawyers I'm saying
everyone you know some of the most
compelling testimony January uh six
committee was his Insider saying Mr
President is not there there's no
there's no fraud you know Bill Barr Mr
President's BS and they asked they'll
borrow what did the president say he
didn't accept it he argued back he
pushed back in every single instance so
again the legal realm is not satisfying
in these respects I was I I would think
a number of people supporting this
resolution they want a certain moral and
political outcome impeachment didn't
work
um they're going to this and he
committed impeachable offenses up the
Wazoo okay but you can't uh prosecute
someone for an impeachable offense of
this nature it was a political offense
it was a moral offense against our
system once again again into the legal
realm it's just a whole different Zone
and I'm afraid David hasn't made the
case on that but Rich by your logic if
he fired a gun on Fifth anyone killed
somebody and then he went in and said I
don't believe I did it
well I don't believe it there's a dead
body their fingerprints on the gun and
there's a bullet that can be traced to
the gun that see there there it's not
murky it's it's a clear violation of the
law and if you got him on that I'm
willing to be open to maybe their
something like that emerges but it
hasn't yet I think it says quite a lot
doesn't it that
Rich you're saying there would pretty
much have to be a dead body on the
streets with Donald J Trump's
fingerprints on him
it would have to be something clear yeah
a clear violation of the law you know a
meeting with The Oath Keepers in in the
White House the week before you guys are
storming the capital I know about the
capital here's a map here's where you
guys go all right
um a speech on January on the morning of
January 6 attack the capital that's what
incitement is the United States has a
First Amendment and incitement is not
protected but is narrowly drawn not to
intrude on Free Speech rights so you got
to say go attack the capital
that's incitement I I'd be in favor of
indicting him in a minute on that but
that's not what he said in fact he
covered himself by saying you know be
peaceful court of law now you might say
be peaceful roll your eyes court of law
and that's the realm you want in you
want to get out of the moral political
realm you want in the legal realm Court
law that's going to matter
there are questions coming in and
actually I think what I'd like to do is
encourage those who are listening
perhaps especially those of the 14 who
don't know what they think yet about
whether Donald Trump should be
prosecuted uh encouraging you to to
bring in your questions I'm going to
start bringing in a few because I think
they'll add to the themes that we can
kind of back back and forth and kind of
explore a little more
um actually the first question that came
in says does Rich believe Trump has
broken any laws since the start of his
successful presidential campaign
so I believe he's broken any laws
um
no
I I
um
[Music]
this this is the problem is so often in
U.S politics and this has been true
since Watergate we want to say because
someone did something wrong we disagree
with or
represented a threat to the
Constitutional system it must be a
violation of the law now I think the
repurposing of the military funding to
go to build the border wall was an abuse
was illegal
um but it wasn't you know it's not a
crime the way we're talking about this
Barack Obama did the same thing when he
rewrote immigration law Union
unilaterally to regularize the status of
a bunch of illegal immigrants that also
was illegal but you wouldn't prosecute
Barack Obama for it you wouldn't
prosecute Trump for that it's
impeachable it's it's technically
impeachable you want a higher level I
think of political offense to impeach
but again just because something's bad
and I thought David was very powerful on
this in his opening remarks it doesn't
make it illegal and if you get it into
the legal realm it's not it's not
healthy and good for a country we should
we should argue our politics out in the
political realm to the extent it gets
into the legal realm it's we've already
seen some of this it's going to hollow
out our our legal institutions
especially if you're stretching to get
someone because you consider them
especially noxus that creates the
predicate for someone else stretching
and you're not going to like it when
they stretch to get your side don't do
it that's that's my um
make the moral case don't do this so
rich you would argue that all of the
efforts Trump made and his people around
him made to get Mike Pence
as vice president to stand up and stop
the count in the Congress all of those
efforts are just free speech
I think they're wrong they're grossly
I'm not asking whether they're wrong
they can agree that they're wrong but a
president of the United States
is organizing his power to get his vice
president to stop the count to stop a
legitimate Congressional function
is just his free speech and not well as
a legal matter it's not illegal it's
grossly wrong and impeachable and in
fact he was impeached for it but would
you just I know you wouldn't prosecute
him but Jamie Raskin is he guilty of a
crime the Democratic congressman from
Maryland because he objected to electors
when you know George W Bush was was
elected or or Trump was elected is that
that's a crime or is it actually part of
the process where you have this push and
pull
um on uh over electors and debate about
it and if someone's if someone's grossly
violates the spirit of the system
you impeach them can I just at this
point bring in something that could
change the facts that could change the
shape of this debate over the coming
days or weeks and I'm thinking about the
Mar-A-Lago raid
um David your thoughts first on whether
you believe Donald Trump could be
prosecuted or jailed for espionage
well it actually doesn't matter what I
believe if indeed under the Three Laws
cited in the war we don't have the
affidavit yet to know the detailed
argument for it but if in any one of
those three laws cited Espionage Act
then section 1519 and section 27 one of
the federal code if indeed Trump took
top secret and Beyond top secret
documents to Mar-A-Lago all on his own
uh having no right to do it uh are you
hearing me okay yeah you're fine yeah
okay okay
um uh and and
the justice department chooses to go to
court in other words they indict him and
chooses to go to court and they can
demonstrate that yes he ordered people
to put those in boxes and get them out
of here and get them on the airplane in
some chaotic situation he violated the
law so maybe that ultimately is where
the case will be made but I do think the
justice department has a hell of a lot
to work with from the January 6th
committee already but this approach is
this is a deeply illiberal approach if
you forgive me usually what we do we
look for violations of the law and then
we see someone violates them and then we
go after that person you don't focus on
a particular person say maybe I can get
them on this I don't give them this I
get them on that I don't get them in
that I can really stretch and maybe get
him on this that's not the way it's
supposed to work and and you didn't even
know about me last week uh you've had
legal Jairus at both sides saying this
is a really bad way to go about it and
the problem you're going to have you
know we need to know the facts I mean
the facts are facts are always important
what was going on in Mar-A-Lago but you
can't say James Comey as I'm not saying
you say this David maybe believe Hillary
Clinton should have been prosecuted they
can't say James Comey was a great Act of
statesmanship to choose not to prosecute
Hillary Clinton for her violations of
the handling of classified material and
then say we got to get Trump those
things don't add up and if you try to do
it you will cause this conflagration
because people will not accept the
legitimacy of it they'll think it's
unfair and selective and again that's
getting your politics into the the legal
realm and destroying your legal system
I think this is relevant at this point
David Tom asks how do or perhaps how
could Trump voters get on board as
prosecution if you're making the case
for prosecution and you're sitting in a
room full of loyal Trump voters David
what do you say to them above all
well I will try to make them talk you
might feel like you're in the Lion's Den
a little uncomfortable what's your best
argument and the rich is even going to
have trouble with those people they're
going to hate him more than me
um but I'm gonna try to get them to talk
to me about facts I'm going to try to
get them to talk to me about questions
of Truth and then I'm going to try to
get them to talk to me about complicity
by the president of the United States in
fermenting that mob that attacked the
U.S Capitol and then if it's above
Mar-A-Lago I will ask them to withhold
judgment until the justice department
however long it takes them
decides whether to indict to charge or
not and if they do I would simply ask
them to read these laws
to read the actual content of of the
federal code and actually perhaps
millions of Americans are reading the
federal code for the first time this is
a good a good historical legal education
I would ask them to simply try to have
an open mind that this is not just an
attempt to get trump it is so so we need
to know about the raid in Mar-A-Lago
until last week